In 2019, Game of Thrones ended.
Game of Thrones is why Alt Shift X took off
in the first place – in 2014, our first
Thrones video explored R+L=J, the granddaddy
of Thrones theories.
That video came out after Game of Thrones
Season 4 – arguably the high point of the
series – and rode off Thrones’ popularity
to start an audience for Alt Shift X.
In 2015, we started this Patreon, which makes
it possible to make more videos, without sacrificing
quality – Alt Shift X is about deep research,
clear explanations, and nice visuals, with
no clickbait, and no bullshit.
With your support over the last 5 years, we
developed a style, hit one million subscribers,
and made a hundred videos – we covered Westworld,
The Expanse, Game of Bones…
But mostly Game of Thrones and A Song of Ice
and Fire – Cersei, Rhaegar, Bloodraven,
Stark mysteries, and videos on every Thrones
episode since Season 6.
Now that Thrones is over, Alt Shift X will
keep evolving.
We’ll make more videos on the Game of Thrones
books, and we’ll cover more new series.
And this is only possible with the support
of our Patrons, so we held a Patron survey
to decide which series to cover.
Patrons want more videos about the Game of
Thrones books – so of course, we’ll make
lots more ASOIAF videos, like the recent Dayne
video and an upcoming Pink Letter video.
We’ll hold more votes on Patreon to choose
future topics like Euron’s eldritch apocalypse,
the Dorne plot, Hardhome, the Blackfyres – there’s
lots more lore, theories and analysis to cover.
There’s also the possibility that the long-awaited
Winds of Winter will come.
George Martin suggested that Winds will be
out by July 2020, for what that’s worth.
When and if Winds comes, we’ll cover it
with recap videos, livestreams, breakdowns
– it’ll be fucking nuts.
There are also GOT prequel shows coming, but
they’re pretty far off, and in the meantime,
there are other cool shows to cover.
The second most popular series in the survey
is Westworld.
Westworld is ambitious and messy and lavish
and smart and dumb and a joy to watch.
Westworld Season 3 seems to focus on Dolores,
Bernard and Jesse Pinkman, and will apparently
be more focussed than the bombastic Season
2.
So we’ll cover Season 3, probably with weekly
videos.
If you’re interested, Patreon supporters
can watch the uncensored version of the Alt
Schwift X Westworld Rant video that’s blocked
on YouTube.
The third most popular series in the survey
is Lord of the Rings – Amazon is spending
a bajillion dollars on an upcoming LOTR TV
show, and it might be worth making videos
about, if it’s complex, and draws from the
books, and is… good.
But either way, it’ll be an excuse to talk
about the original story that defined modern
fantasy.
The fourth most popular series is Watchmen
– our Watchmen 2019 video will be out very
soon.
And we can totally do more Watchmen videos
– like maybe one on the visual storytelling
and symbolism of the original comic.
Also popular in the survey was Witcher, The
Expanse, Dune, His Dark Materials, and real-world
sciency history stuff.
Witcher we haven’t watched yet, but it might
be worth some videos before Season 2.
We can definitely do more Expanse, maybe a
video about the protomolecule or something
before Season 5.
Dune has a movie coming out in 2020, so now’s
a great time to talk about spice and sand
worms.
For His Dark Materials, we could do a video
about Dust and the story’s big ideas in
Book 1 / Season 1.
As for science / history / edu stuff, we’ve
got ideas for some cool videos about the real
world – Alt Shift X began with videos about
science and philosophy, a long time ago.
So that’s the rough plan for Alt Shift X
in 2020 – more ASOIAF, more Westworld, probably
Expanse Dune His Dark Materials edu, Lord
of the Rings when it’s done, and whatever
other cool stories come up – comment below
if you’ve got more ideas.
We can’t do everything – but we’ll hold
votes on Patreon, see which shows are good,
and make some kickass videos.
For votes, updates, livestreams, and Patron-only
content, join the Patreon at patreon.com/AltShiftX.
There are Patron-only videos about symbolism
in Watchmen, and His Dark Materials, and the
uncensored Westworld Rant, and more.
So thank you for watching, and thanks to the
Patrons for your support.
Thank you for the last five years, for sticking
with Alt Shift X through the highs and the
lows of Game of Thrones.
Here’s to five years more.
Oh and I swear we’ll do that Alt Shift Podcast
one day, it’s gonna happen, uh shoutout
to Alt Schwift X, Alt Shift ZZZ, Random Article,
Internet Historian, VaatiVidya, and all those
other Alt Shift X side-channels.
Cheers.